Welcome back!
We're about to start unit 4, and one of the things we're going to cover
is the suprising power you can get from just writing down something
you've already computed and referring back to it later.
That actually came up once in my life.
A number of years ago, I had the priviledge of working for Microsoft Research
on a project to try to find and fix bugs in Windows.
Now most of you are probably watching from a moon based in the not too distant future,
but in the present and in the past, bugs in Windows were a big deal.
In fact, it would often crash and lead to the dreaded blue screen of death.
It turned out that as much as we like to pick on Microsoft,
most of the bugs weren't in Microsoft code, but in third-party code
written to drive various bits of hardware, like screens or printers or memory sticks.
This software was called Device Drivers, and it might work something like
this memory stick that I have right here.
Microsoft wrote a tool to put this Device Driver software through torture tests.
If you're memory stick, I might add data to you and then in the middle of reading it out,
pull you out or turn off the power, or in general, apply these normal operations very fast
or in a surprising order.
And this really worked. They found a lot of bugs.
So many bugs that's it's now a shipping product--the Microsoft Static Driver Verifier.
The heart of this idea was a computer science notion known as model checking,
figuring out how a program behaves by looking at its source code.
A key to that was remembering things that had already been computed.
If I already know how you behave when I turn off the power in the middle of an operation,
I don't have to recompute it, which might be very expensive.
So this relatively simple notion of writing down things so that we don't have to recompute them,
is formerly called memoization, and it's one of the gems we'll get to in this unit.